lo que nos hemos encontrado en esta
corta visita a alice chang es calles
vacías como esta y eso que llegamos en
un momento del día donde la población
que todavía se encuentra en la ciudad
sale a hacer sus compras a proveerse de
alimentos oa tomar un poco de sol nos
dicen que por ejemplo los combates
fueron tan grandes ayer que no salieron
a la calle hoy era el primer día después
de varios días que lo que lo hacían pero
también nos hemos encontrado con algunos
sectores de la ciudad donde han sido
atacados destrucción cómo están algunos
edificios residenciales con las ventanas
quebradas sin embargo la mayor parte de
la población que hemos visto está
básicamente intacta no así lo que vemos
el severodonezk en la población de al
lado más grande que está donde vemos
bastantes columnas de humo hemos visto
que gran parte de la población ha
partido vimos a personas que estaban
intentando salir esperando alguna ayuda
humanitaria pero también tampoco hemos
visto presencia de las tropas ucranianas
no hubo un gran número dentro de la
ciudad si en el perímetro de la ciudad
que sigue siendo
diputado hay bastantes enfrentamientos
hay ataques hay bombardeos hay
artillería que suena a lo lejos es
interesante porque la gente parece
haberse acostumbrado sigue haciendo su
vida normal pero lo que sí da a entender
hablando entre líneas con los militares
es que la situación en esta provincia de
lugares cada vez está peor especialmente
en esta área